let's jump to this story from Fox
Business in in light of what you're
bringing up musk is planning to release
the Twitter files on Free Speech
suppression public deserves to know so
uh of course I sat down with you know
Rogan and and Jack and Vijay and I
believe they outright lied to us that
the whole thing was just lies had they
lied under oath too I I don't know about
them but I'm willing to bet Twitter
staff probably have lied on Underoath
the Congress or the very least they've
lied to Congress or even less than that
been wrong to come sure it's great we'll
we'll hear what's going on I gotta say
though the Twitter files I am I would
bet a substantial amount of money that
they have files on child exploitation
where there's a manager saying like hey
don't do anything because it'll draw
attention to us and it'll be bad for the
stock price stuff like that oh my God
would you agree they were probably
behind the scenes I am so I I'm praying
with every fiber of my being that you're
wrong like that's something that's so
like purely evil that to have that in
writing it's it's just so what do you
expect
it's just horrifying to even think about
it why weren't they taking it down
yeah that's a great question that's
that's a very long Elon snaps his finger
he I that's unfair he's working very
hard getting everybody saying shut it
down and it's disappearing
yeah and and these people at Twitter
were taking advantage of the power and
responsibility they had for their own
personal benefit for the personal
benefit of the power in for the powers
in charge for the government for the
intelligence agencies for the
multinational corporations that are
calling the shots there uh so they're
capable of doing a lot of very
underhanded evil things and I think Elon
Musk even a couple days ago was tweeting
hey you know it's far worse than I even
expected it to be and I bet there's
probably so much evil so much just nasty
actions being committed by these people
that that a lot of people can't even
imagine how how bad it gets let me ask
you uh uh Ian because you worked for
mines and you actually saw a lot of the
content that violated I can't imagine
like based on your experience how bad
you think it is with Twitter people
posting this stuff it's got to be
magnitudes worse because there's
magnitudes more people using it and I
mean like times 10 times 10 times
there's probably a 10 000 more times
more people using it so I'd imagine
there's ten thousand times more what I
mean it's probably even more than that
because it's a centralized focus of
interaction you you actually had to deal
with moderation when it came to this
kind of yeah and I'm wondering if the
FBI went to Twitter and was like oh
that's child porn leave it up it's a
Honeypot now let's see everybody that
shares it and comments on it those are
the people yeah the federal government
has run many adult child websites
um and the stories of what they were
doing is absolutely shocking what about
the Bungie boys and is that how it's
pronounced in Afghanistan I don't know
so right yeah our allies in Afghanistan
had a thing where they would bring out
young boys and have their way with them
and basically the uh look this is also
New York Times the Europe armed forces
were told they're on our team look the
other way this isn't our problem and
then and then the soldiers that spoke
out against it were court-martialed and
punished that were trying to stop it
your tax dollars were paying for the U.S
military protecting and aiding small
children being hurt in more ways than
once I wanted to come here and make some
Jew jokes you are and they're hilarious
hey the Balenciaga stuff opens again
yeah but look look okay
we can talk about I mean what's going on
with Twitter because it's not just
obvious obviously the dark dark stuff
but we're probably going to see overt
political bias we're probably going to
see election interference outright them
saying the hunter Biden thing absolutely
there's no question right LH
interference and they're probably going
to be saying in in the private chats
this is going to help uh Biden win or we
have to stop Trump things like that yeah
yeah there's no question that's it's
dark but I've lightened it yeah no no no
that is that is the
um although the hunter Biden with the
the net with the niece and whatever
that's a whole other situation here we
go again yep no but I I there was this
Norm Macdonald uh meme which I don't
think he ever really said uh where the
quote ascribed to Norm which is I'm
starting to think that the the pedophile
devil worshipers who run our government
don't have our best interest at heart
um and there's a lot of Truth to that
yes absolutely I'm wondering what other
when they pull up these Twitter files
that elon's talking about if they're
gonna they're gonna find words that have
been down can I make everyone even more
depressed let's do it hell yes let's do
it please do let's go so uh the thing
that really upsets me is the virtual
certainty that nothing will happen is
their consequence of this and let me
give you an example when this happened
we all remember that Brett Kavanaugh
hearings and the what do you where do
you think of Christine blasey Ford Julie
swetnik was an example where it
absolutely you know she's saying that
Kavanaugh was at these parties where
there was trains run on her it's like
why are you going back to these parties
Michael avenetti was her lawyer people
were tripping over themselves to put her
on TV it turned out her story made no
sense it didn't add up she never met
Kavanaugh so and so forth
um Chuck Grassley Charles Grassley was
just re-elected who was I think head of
the Judiciary Committee ranking hardcore
Republican he put out a press release
earlier this year how he wrote a letter
to both the Department of Justice and
the FBI asking for follow-up but someone
who lied to you know affect a free Court
nomination and they didn't bother reply
neither bothered replying to him and
then he wrote them another another
letter and this is his press release see
I'm writing letters that are completely
ignored vote for me so the fact that
he's boasting about the fact that he
can't even get a like someone on the
phone from the Department of Justice or
the FBI about something that is Central
to our legal system just speaks to me
how little appetite there is in
Washington among members of both parties
to have any kind of repercussions for
this and another great example of this
is I really drives me crazy when Boomer
conservatives think oh pedophiles are
Democrats like as if it's somehow like
you know they're into kids but they're
also just socialized medicine
um the Speaker of the House Dennis
Hester was a predator on young boys and
he went to jail as a consequence for
things that have to do with this issue
the Democrats never bring it up they
never use this as a cudgel they never
say why you'd bring back Dennis
hastert's money they're more interested
in talking about like Margaret Taylor
green or Trump or or George W bush who's
now a good guy so that to me is very
very disturbing
I have not given up on politics but I'm
so disinterested in attempting to use
that corrupt system to fix a world that
was we need to make like Politics As a
result of a healthy Society so let's
build a healthy Society then there will
be politics
man I'm trying I'm trying to get him to
exercise that's been we had you you said
you wanted to do it yesterday I told you
you want to do it enraged after the show
I think you need to read this book
you can only help people so much you got
to open the door they got to walk
through I wanna I wanna mention just as
we're talking about this subject and and
boy are we in it I guess because the
Balenciaga stuff we really needed to
talk about this but there's there is a
positive for us who are challenging
these things trying to get these things
taken down grateful to Elon Musk for
putting a stop to this and it's that I
was talking to a friend and I said
something like as as semi-facetiously
like oh yeah like you know people
believe that a cabal of powerful Global
Elites are trafficking kids and doing
weird things pause because now we know
they are because of Epstein and
Maxwell's conviction hey that's funny
right if you said that a few years ago
people would call you crazy but
something happened and now we know they
they it happened they're doing it
Maxwell locked up because of it and now
we're still sitting here wondering who
are their clients right so not only do
we know it happened we know there are
still people who have never been held to
account she went down for providing
um you know a service for clients that
weren't there that absolutely doesn't
make sense and and this wasn't the first
time that there have been major
government officials caught in these
larger horrible things that they were
doing to Children Dennis hassert is one
of them the former prime minister of the
United Kingdom Edward Heath another
major one no no no I looked him up Ed
Heath it's it's ambiguous so let's give
him some credit I mean when he's hanging
out with Jimmy Seville I didn't know he
was hanging out with Jimmy Seville yeah
I mean Heath was we don't have receipts
on Heath who's who's Heath by the way he
was the Margaret he was the Prime
Minister of the Margaret Thatcher
dethroned I talked him out of my next
book yeah but but but but again there
are many the chains yes there's we just
keep going how many times and how many
instances there are of government using
your tax dollars to facilitate some of
the most atrocious horrible acts on the
face I think it was in 1969 1971 uh if
you look up like French philosophers
declaration a bunch of prominent French
philosophers including soccer 70s 70s
where they all signed a letter saying
that uh age of consent laws should be
abolished wow yeah it's wild there's
there's evil out there so please look it
up okay I want to talk about evil and
cabals because you're saying these
conspiracy theories people don't know if
they're real or not this is very known
right right like the Epstein stuff is is
is it's no longer the room of conspiracy
Maxwell was convicted I want to shout I
want to shout out uh Phoenix 499 who
super chatted us saying all you need to
know is that Maxwell was the first
person to conv to be convicted of
trafficking kids to nobody yeah so so
there's people out there these are evil
people they've gotten away with it for
now
and then one more let's get to the
little personal I was on Rogan a couple
years ago because a friend of mine Matt
and he told me to use his name he came
out to me because he had been the victim
of childhood sexual abuse and the reason
I bring this up every so often is it's
still one of those things where there's
such a stigma to it that people are
scared to talk about it like if I found
out that your mom you know was an
alcoholic I'd feel bad for you Luke but
our friendship wouldn't really change if
I found out you know something happened
with you Ian but this is the kind of
thing where people are scared to say
something because if you talk to them
about it they think you're going to
think they're wounded bird you're gonna
think they're freak you're not gonna be
able to make certain kinds of jokes
about them as a result of this this
social stigma they keep it silent you
know for the rest of their lives which
is really really making a victim even
worse and after I was on Rogan I talked
about this four more of my friends came
out to me so if I know five people that
means I definitely know more that means
this happens a lot more than people
realize and until people start talking
about it and normalizing coming out and
accepting people who've had this done to
them they're going to keep getting away
with it because the reason these people
get away with it is like don't tell
anyone and that you're a kid you're not
going to know any better so it's a very
very uh disturbing cycle that hopefully
we're going to be able to break uh in
the very near future you think it's just
by normalizing sexuality adult sexuality
in our society no no like like people
are afraid to talk about sex and then
they go and and shame watch porn and
abuse kids like if they have a healthy
conversation about it maybe it will
prevent that kind of behavior nobody
no I I can't I can't give you this one
we live in the see what I have to deal
with I got to deal with this every day
we are the result of Puritans and they
were very anti like it was Puritan
puritanical has that adjective attached
to it for a reason is because it's like
no sex this might be the most you've
gone full Ian this is the most this is I
almost did porn man this is like should
I be doing porn right now should I be
waking people up to the idea that
sexuality is okay I I completely agree
sexuality is okay if you want to do porn
I'll support you thank you but I think
this is something very different from
people you know not talking about what
kind of sex they have as opposed to like
awful things were done to me as a kid
and they didn't use force and on some
level it was pleasurable and I was
confused because I was a child and I
wasn't physically hurt they didn't
punish me I didn't know how to feel
about the time and now as an adult I
still don't know how to feel about it
and this says disturb me all my life and
I'm turning to drugs or alcohol because
I don't know how to deal with it the
record my opinion Hunter Biden perhaps
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time